- We won in the Revolution.
- We won in everything.
- America.
(classical piano and cello music)
- Maltesers.
Isn't that a dog? A Maltese?
- It kinda tastes like a more
chocolatey Kit Kat to me.
- If Whoppers had more chocolate
around it, that is that.
- How the chocolate's
like unusually smooth.
- You could sneak this into
the movies, like really easily.
- Ooh, this is good movie candy.
Like you could put it with your popcorn?
- Nice packaging, though.
- Yeah. It's cute.
- Can just, like, hide it in a purse.
- Like if it was the
only thing in the house
I would still eat it.
- Why would they call it Dairy Milk?
It's a chocolate bar.
- Isn't all milk dairy?
- Dairy Milk sounds like a yogurt brand,
or like, if I was gonna
buy, like ricotta cheese.
- This reminds me of the
Willy Wonka wrapping.
- I was kind of expecting
something to be in the
middle, 'cause they look like pockets.
- This is solid.
Like, you could build
something with these.
- You know how there's,
like, Double Stuf Oreos,
it's like a Double Stuf Hershey's.
I would prefer a Hershey's bar over this.
- [Voiceover] Yorkie.
- [Voiceover] Isn't there a
candy already titled Yorkies?
- Dogs are cute. Maybe--
- Hope the chocolate's cute.
- Haha, looks like a Lego.
(chocolate snaps)
- Ooh!
(laughs)
It's very dense.
- It's like the chocolate on Nestle Crunch
but without the crunch.
- A weak Ghirardelli.
- Nothing special. Pretty generic.
- [Voiceover] Flake. New peel and reveal.
- Cover Girl, like, "New peel and reveal!"
Like, something like that.
- It sounds like a face mask.
- This looks very interesting.
- It's like bark. It looks like trees. Oh.
(giggles)
- It has a weird texture.
- It confuses me.
- It definitely lives up to the name.
- Yeah.
- It's very flaky.
- It kind of tastes like the powder
you make with hot chocolate?
- There's, like, a buttery taste to it.
- It tastes very good! I'm impressed.
- [Voiceover] Toffee Crisp.
- [Voiceover] It looked like
Reese's when I first saw it.
- I don't know what toffee is.
- Oh. Oh, wow.
- All right.
- Oh, I like this. It
has so much happening.
- Say, like a combination
of a Kit Kat and a Twix?
- Crispy, chewy. True.
- Wow.
- Mmm, this is good.
- It's kinda like a
crunch bar on the bottom.
- Wow.
- I don't know what's
in the middle of this.
Something crunchy.
- It's toffee! That's what toffee is.
- That's what, oh, then, I
guess that's what toffee is.
- Wow!
- Why don't they just change the wrapper?
That just seems easy.
- I'm almost borderlining
on emotionally unstable if
these aren't going to
be in America anymore.
'Cause we're really just
starting out a new relationship
here, and I'm feeling
like it's really positive.
(classical piano and cello music)
(swishing and old, creaky sign swinging)